en lysychansk escenas como éstas se han
vuelto habituales junto a los equipos de
rescate los ciudadanos ayudan a buscar y
sacar cuerpos entre los escombros tras
un bombardeo ruso y abundó
y estaba en casa oí la explosión cenizas
y polvo sabía una columna de polvo
subiendo oí a alguien llorar gritos
terribles corrí hacia aquí y sólo vi
ruinas y cuerpos se los llevaban en
camillas no sé algunos estaban vivos
otros muertos y
los proyectiles alcanzaron el centro
cultural de la ciudad refugio de decenas
de ciudadanos y también en las casas de
muchos vecinos que ahora temen por su
integridad física y también al olvido la
memoria de 60 niños manos llenas va a
pasar nosotros mismos no sabemos qué va
a pasar mañana
hay que terminar esta guerra terminarla
negociar somos personas mayores que no
tenemos dónde ir dónde voy a ir yo tengo
72 años me dejarán en algún pueblo en
alguna parte
algunos como elena han decidido
trasladarse a refugios oscuros para
intentar evitar las bombas a toda costa
algo que no calma su desesperación ya
que aunque pudieran salir del refugio ya
no tienen a donde ir
no sé cómo expresar lo con palabras la
gente tiene miedo esto es la guerra da
miedo no hay comunicación
no se puede salir a ningún sitio no hay
lugar al que ir la ofensiva de las
tropas rusas se ha centrado en la región
oriental del donbass donde se encuentran
ciudades como lysychansk o severodonezk
de donde muchos civiles intentan huir
desesperadamente